seth rogen and james franco go way way
back the pair start alongside one
another and creator judd apatow
short-lived series freaks and geeks
in which rogan played ken miller and
franco portrayed his pal daniel diserio
freaks and geeks not only served as
rogan's introduction into hollywood it
was his first ever professional acting
role but it also marked the beginning of
what would become a long-standing
creative partnership of sorts with
franco
after freaks and geeks ended in 2000
rogan teamed up with franco to star in
the 2008 apatow co-produced stoner
comedy pineapple express
he then enlisted franco to star in his
feature film directorial debut this is
the end in 2013
and tapped franco to be part of his and
evan goldberg's controversial political
comedy the interview in 2014.
rogan is also starred in a number of
franco's films the 2014 drama the sound
and the fury the 2017 movie the disaster
artist
and the 2019 dramedy zero bill plus
rogan and franco each voiced characters
in the raunchy 2016
animated movie sausage party obviously
rogan and franco have been something of
a dynamic duo in hollywood over the last
two decades
however rogan has now come forward to
assert that he's not keen on associating
with franco any longer
the shady side of james franco has
surfaced multiple times over the years
and the most damning allegations against
the actor have been the accusations of
sexual misconduct
lodged by several different women the
first incident of what many consider
misconduct came to light in april 2014
when screenshots of instagram direct
messages between james franco and a then
17 year old girl were posted online to
the photo sharing site imager
as business insider details the teenager
was visiting new york city where franco
was performing as george in the broadway
adaptation of up mice and men and met
the then 35 year old franco after seeing
the play
they took a photo together then franco
found her on instagram after she tagged
him in the photo and began messaging her
franco asked a teenager when her 18th
birthday was if she had a boyfriend and
if he could meet her at her hotel
the interaction which franco admitted
did happen drew controversy for the fact
that franco was more than twice the
girl's age
despite her being of the age of consent
in both new york 17
and her home country of scotland 16. in
january 2018
franco's ex-girlfriend violet paley came
forward with allegations of sexual
assault against the actor a few days
later the los angeles times reported
that five women
all of whom had taken acting lessons
from franco lodged allegations of sexual
misconduct against him as well
another sexual misconduct lawsuit filed
by two more former students of franco's
came to light in october 2019.
in february 2021 franco reportedly
reached the settlement with these two
women
in a may 2021 interview with the sunday
times rogan got candid about his
relationship with franco particularly
upon reflection of the multiple
allegations of sexual misconduct that
had been filed against franco as rogan
explained to the outlet back in 2018 he
told an interviewer that he would
continue working with franco but that's
no longer his intention
rogan made it very clear that he has no
plans to work with franco in the future
rogan told the sunday times what i can
say is that i despise abuse and
harassment and i would never cover or
conceal the actions of someone doing it
or knowingly put someone in a situation
where they were around someone like that
i also look back to that interview in
2018 where i comment that i would keep
working with james and the truth is that
i have not
and i do not plan to right now rogan
also expressed regret about a 2014
saturday night live opening monologue in
which he made a joke about the
aforementioned real life event in which
franco was direct messaging a teenager
on instagram
since the two actors are old friends
this begs the question have the
allegations against franco impacted
their friendship as well
rogan shared with the sunday times i
don't know if i can define that right
now during this interview
i can't say it um you know it has
changed many things in our relationship
and our dynamic
yeah but not as painful and difficult as
it is for a lot of other people involved
i have no pity for myself in this
situation
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available
visit the rape abuse and incest national
network website or contact
reigns national helpline at
1-800-656-hope
4673